maintenant on va parler de vous avait
prévenu j'avais marée noire personnage
qui rires non mais ma vie quand on
commence à m à la loire alain barrière
alors vous êtes né en 1946
oui vous avez passé l'enfance à
cruseilles dans un village à côté de
thonon les bains dans une maison bleue
adossée à la colline une chance ans j'ai
encore une chanson reste les commerçants
de willamette entente c'est une maison
qui était adossée à la colline en plus
c'est vrai il habite en voilà vous êtes
cynique et vos parents travaillent et
aux impôts on connaît la chanson
on connaît la chanson c'est le cas de le
dire à on arrive à la question là on
arrive à la fiche 69 c'est que la tige
65 donc là non c'est pas porno du tout
mais les rôles sont inversés
versez vous cacher les positions que
j'ai envie vous en faites par andré
quand même alors posez moi n'importe
quelle question qui vous passe par la
tête j'ai obligé d'y répondre
pourquoi est-ce qu'on vous copie dans
thierry et
et pour toi et pour toi
pourquoi ça vous énerve autant ça
devrait vous flatter fait d'être copiés
c'est plutôt flatteur
voilà ça prouve qu'il ya pas beaucoup
d'idées dans le paf en ce moment et est
passé en bas c'est bon ça bien alors
donc cruseilles mille habitants c'est
pas c'est pas énorme 1 4 enfants par
classe évidemment quand on est quatre
par classe ça vous oblige est bon
l'instituteur jeunesse 4e 3e 2e 3e ex
aequo d'études extrême solitude gérons
rien belle 6000 habitants 4 par classe
les parents aux impôts bon rêver c'est
vrai quoi là d un jour et un jour vous
avez enfermer un camarade il enfermé un
de ses camarades dans une dans sa
chambre ouais il voulait partir ils en
avaient assez et marre de jouer pendant
depuis trois heures avec moi et et là
j'ai paniqué j'ai affirmé
et je voulais pas qu'ils s'en aillent
j'ai réalisé quand même que j'étais en
train de commettre un acte un peu
étrange et donc j'ai rouvert la porte
mais c'était pour vous dire ma détresse
on est donc dans cette solitude ya un
grand bouleversement heureusement à
l'âge de 10 ans votre prof de français
j'emmène voir poil de carotte de jules
renard et là vous découvrez qui a
finalement des gens qui sont payés pour
faire rire voilà et ça c'est génial tout
ce que je ne pourrais pas faire vraiment
dans la vie c'est dire pleurer rire
enfin je sais pas il y avait pas
tellement d'interlocuteurs en 4 1 donc
là tout d'un côté anne avec en plus des
personnes qui étaient là dans une salle
qui applaudissait qui paient même pour
voir ça ça j'ai trouvé que c'était
formidable de pouvoir libérer des
émotions que dans la vie j'avais
tendance
et puis donc ça c'est paul théâtre répit
au cinéma le premier film que vous voyez
sur les 400 coups de truffaut seul été
autorisé par le fisc est logique donc
qu'il avait le droit d'y aller et c'est
vraiment basses que quelques années plus
tard vous ferez votre premier film avec
avec truffaut c'est extraordinaire oui
évidemment vous voyez les 400 coups mais
vos parents vous dise passe d'abord
tombe à 15 ce qu'ils disent je dise à
tout le monde vous allez très serré
comme gars engrais très obéissante
réseau wifi sont gentils garçons
j pl obéissant il va à la fac de
grenoble si vous dites à la plaque des
grenades pas me jouer piétiner les
pantalons sans respecter les plis parce
que la maison fallait bien faire le plus
du passé ou ouvrir jaser tout comme il
faut en apparence que ça mais j'avais un
petit peu des excès mais que je ne
racontais papilles quand je suis passé à
grenoble
là il y avait un petit kilomètre entre
la famille et moi et là j'ai pu à vous
sortez l'université avec une maîtrise de
lettres modernes et une licence sont en
maîtrise de lettres modernes et une
licence de wingles mystique mais j'ai
tout oublié à n'être pas capable
d'interroger sur la philologie vous
refuser un poste à oran oui d'assistant
philologie justement pour monter à paris
la voie là vous devenez élèves de 2
périmony de cocher vous allez au
conservatoire et c'est là que truffaut
vous voyez vous vous choisi vous jouiez
léonce et léna exacte et sur scène en ce
moment d'ailleurs à paris et vous fait
faire un premier film s'appelle une
belle fille comme moi hein vous déguiser
parce que c'est vrai que là on parlait
de vidocq tout à l'heure c'est vrai que
face à permet d'être là font donc
banquiers comme moi vous avez des
lunettes des gongs jaune cercle
rogner un peu pour pacino de l'époque
c'était l'époque où il y avait aux fans
pacino de niro et caetera et pour moi
c'était ça le métier de comédien on les
reconnaissait pas d'un rôle à l'autre et
là avec ce rôle là c'est un timide
introverti du net et tout donc je j'ai
joué j'ai composé un personnage mais
finalement je les payais un peu après
parce que on s'attendait à ce que j'ai
des gants jaunes des lunettes de vue
vous êtes dit quand même pauvre
apprentis du cinéma qui veut jouer comme
dustin hoffman et ya peu j'ai pas encore
assez armé à mon avis pour le fait bien
mieux mais c'était quand même une
approche truffaut avait l'air content et
de films étaient pas totalement
truffaldien si on n'a pas des super bien
marché non il n'ya pas super bien marché
alors l'échec du premier film d'une
certaine façon oui toute une vie avec
claude lelouch un échec aussi oui
difficile où c'est bizarre si nbc raison
des forts mais c'est bien j'ai commencé
par le plus dur donc après ça a démarré
en fait avec trois hommes et un couffin
on peut dire que j'ai additionner des
films comme ça mais publiquement c'est
vrai que c'est le film qui a eu le plus
de succès vous êtes très discret sur
votre vie privée d'aujourd'hui 1 g
aujourd'hui normes il est très discret
ce soir
non mais bon il ya un truc tout le monde
le sait on peut en parler ya
prescription en bref du tout ce qui veut
dire andré je ne le vois pas venir du
tout pas du tout venir c'était sans
doute une relation
et sexuelle est très longtemps bah
disons pas calé sexuelle ça peut être
gênant vous étiez très proche d'isabelle
adjani un moment à on était collé
guillon c'est une collègue michel
serrault l'onac demandé à mes collègues
de l'art dramatique on était en est
comme en sciences à la comédie française
voilà ce qu elle coûte collègues des
collègues vendée c'est dans les avions a
déclaré donc sur le tournage d'une belle
fille comme moi on pouvait pas trop lui
parler en dehors des scènes parce que
dès qu'il avait un moment de liberté
il s'éclipse et pour écrire adjani
collègues mais ça l'est moins une chose
à lui dire j'ai j'aurai encore beaucoup
de choses à lui dire je voyais beaucoup
elle est un peu happé par sa notoriété
non adjani après très tôt rétabli c'est
vrai à 18 ans elle a connu un immense
succès avec la gifle donc je pense que c
d changement de vie radical qui sont pas
forcément faciles à vivre à cet âge là
hein
voilà vous avez revu je les croise et
oui y compris je les ai pas de
sous-entendus je vais croiser et après
c'est à dire de sa mort et après dans la
loge et elle a félicité
nous avons beaucoup parlé